i am not your failure
i love how they did this with the voice
it's so great yeah
you
didn't kill
anakin
oh okay
specific words they gave to hayden other
words they gave the free speecher
[Music]
it's just so
like it's heartbreaking but like you can
feel obi-wan healing same way
i will destroy you
and my friend is truly wow
this is just brutal
[Music]
oh
yep you called him darth just left him
with darth what an insult i would do
that to my brother when i see him this
weekend
[Music]
i love the
the voice effect there was
top-notch that was that was wow man that
that delivered to me on a level like so
many things this episode yes
so handsome you want to meet him oh
oh
below it oh are we gonna get another
another crying session here yeah
give him his toy
oh give him the toy
luke's just like i don't want this
nothing breaks it in front of him
hello there
he said
[Applause]
he did it
did you did you see the thing they said
about you and mcgregor having so much
fun riding a camel he tried to buy one
what an idiot
what are you gonna do with that camel
rich people man
yes well
i mean he had to show up right i would
have been yeah i would have been
disappointed if we didn't see her here i
think you'd never come
come on
you've got a ways to go
always there
like how how much did you see
yeah wait a second did you watch me
i mean me and me and tikka the jawa got
you some uh
nasty [ __ ]
let's not overthink this
that's all i can think about yes
[Laughter]
all right
well done
well done deborah chow
oh my god
so much happened this episode we have to
talk about it welcome back to new
rockstars obi-wan kenobi's finale pulled
out all the stops with cameos from
qui-gon jinn
somehow palpatine returned kenobi
getting his own ahsoka style peek
through the vader mask and hot damn
hello there and i think we owe it to
darth vader to change up our weekly
darth maul kenobi scream to the version
that vader gave us this episode
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that was good i felt like i was on the
set i felt like i was on the led volume
with you there yeah you transported me
this is wikileaks new rockstars official
after show for obi-wan kenobi i'm eric
boss my easter egg breakdown is gonna
come out tomorrow it's a busy day ahead
of us but right now i'm reacting to this
episode with tommy bechtol tommy
wow what uh
i mean just so much to talk about i
don't even want to waste too much time
saying hello but i will
i just had such a great time with this
episode a lot of my personal theories
coming to fruition a lot i mean
including very specifically on break the
break room yesterday my prediction that
aunt peru was a secret badass uh i think
with that pretty much came
uh that was that was definitely one that
i will be rubbing at everyone's faces uh
tonight this afternoon but uh yeah let's
get into it yeah the hampering moment
the biggest surprise for me absolutely i
love
pamper this episode
you know what it honestly felt like uh
this whole series from the pitch was all
just leading up to this moment and
everything else was just kind of like
tracing our steps up to it in fact i
mean just imagine a scenario where this
could have been all we got for obi-wan
kenobi yeah imagine a story just like a
one-off christmas special that opened
with obi-wan on the run with young leia
on some freighter we don't know what
they're doing how they got there but
there are other jedi there or other
people who think that they're jedi who
are just helping jedi get away but as
they're being chased by the devastator
like that honestly feels like we're
we're jumping right into the deep end in
a new hope with the 10 to four chase
from the star destroyer uh so it
honestly just feels like oh yeah this is
this is everything we needed and i'm
glad we got here i'm so glad we got here
um absolutely well okay so this episode
vader star destroyer the devastator
pursues rokin's freighter obi-wan says
goodbye to broken and hajja tells them
to get leia home uh leia doesn't want to
leave does that little trick of leaving
daddy a toy in a suitcase so he has to
come back home early from the business
trip
lee
lola uh man that tracker she learned a
tip from uh from rita there right you
know that droid it's a great tracker
it's it's good for a lot of stuff uh
well everyone takes a drop ship uh to
this nearby unnamed moon i looked for
the name of the moon uh we didn't get it
i believe the audio description calls it
a desolate moon uh but we don't get a
yeah i mean it looks like a desolation
just name it after yourself tommy i
think you've ever read it i believe they
landed on bechtold four
they i like how whenever they're fleeing
the starter shirt they're literally
doing the zigzag maneuver they're like
it's harder to shoot us
that's how you run away from a gator
right eric i don't even know i'm going
to florida in three days right yeah you
have to zigzag they are fast tommy don't
don't underestimate a gator that's what
they're counting on you know they say
that about me eric you know i may look
heavy but i can run i got fleet feet
also you're cold-blooded and uh
you like just laying in there and i eat
my own eggs uh that i produce i mean i
who wouldn't i mean your eggs are
delicious cadbury cream right that's
right yes they're all cadbury cream some
are cadbury minis but uh
that's you're lucky if you get a cadbury
mooney inside of a bigger cadbury egg oh
my god what an embarrassment of riches
yeah that's what we call a cadbury
double uh tur duck uh tur cadbury is
when it's three
wait put a pin in that we're doing that
next easter for a viral video we're
putting all the cadbury eggs inside of
each other roasting it at 350 for 10
hours
back to the show back to the show um so
a wounded rough-looking riva arrives to
tattooing seeking out owen uh uh getting
in fights with water vendors owen gets
tipped off i love the um the code of
honor between the water
trade of tattooing his water vendor's
like i have to warn you owen yeah i
don't want you to get in trouble you're
like the only moisture farmer who will
sell me at you know under 20 credits per
cup of it and i i can't afford to go to
stephen f root on the other side of the
planet that guy's going to jack up the
prices so he's not yeah he's unethical
and joe's just gonna warn you uh here uh
but owen gets tipped off he warns beru
beru our lady baru pulling that pulling
a regina king and watchman pulling
random rifles at everywhere saying let's
go she was waiting for this moment she
was bored for this moment there was
uh many a day leading up to this droids
were just giving her some side eye like
that woman has gone crazy hiding rifles
behind the flower bed what is she
planning on i love this woman this
episode she is uh she's my new hero of
star wars and she's just like she's a
bit excited and she's like oh someone's
coming yes
yes i get to do this
the plan
all of my hidden weapons will come come
in handy now
yeah she just like pops open uh some
blue bantha milk and inside that carton
is just like another little gun and
she's like let's do it
there's just guns everywhere there's
guns inside of the guns there's a droid
with just a blaster for a head like why
did i exist
now i know kill me
you don't anymore
[Laughter]
so obi-wan and vader share a duel for
the ages of this episode it's incredible
obi-wan has regained to strengthen his
confidence yet vader says but your
weakness remains invader overwhelms him
tries to bury him alive vicious fatality
here but it's not so obi-wan is clinging
to his it seems like his hatred for
anakin at first uh but really he uh
leaves those thoughts behind and instead
focuses on his love for leia and for
luke and he frees himself giving vader
the business at that point slashing his
chest controls slicing open his helmet
just like ahsoka did to vader and rebels
when they reunited giving us a nice
parallel moment here it's beautiful
vader tells him that obi-wan didn't kill
anakin skywalker he did and obi-wan
tells him that his friend is truly dead
and leaves his former padawan wheezing
in pain screaming
incredible
just an incredible exchange here yes i
love my god yes i do too
meanwhile riva sneaks into lars
homestead uh ended up in one hell of a
shootout and uh it looks like a flower
pot fight with owen and brew they're
just throwing anything they can at her
yeah she chases luke across the desert
into a canyon knocking him off a ledge
unconscious and i'm thinking at this
point why she just really wants to kill
him out of revenge i'm not really sure
what she wants to do with yeah i thought
she just
was gonna use him as a hostage to get
obi-wan back
in the picture and then get vader back
in the picture but no she just uh she
knows this boy is important
to uh to somebody and then just wants to
kill him so i'm just glad ultimately
that obviously she didn't come we knew
she wasn't but uh i'm glad that she's
able to like come to this on her own
uh it's it's you know for a second it
seems like counterintuitive storytelling
to like deprive obi-wan of being the
hero in this moment and rescuing luke uh
it's just a change that she encounters
on her own and uh they brought back
young riva the actress to just sit there
on on the on the sand you know so that
like she can have that parallel moment
pretty incredible moment and then um you
know she returns luke back to baru and
owen and obi-wan and bruce like
can i just use four more of my guns i
mean i have i haven't hidden everywhere
beru kind of gives the like i forgive
but i never forget if i see you in these
streets again i will blast three holes
inside of you yeah she just like opens
up her robes
and they're like whoa that's like
naked
and tatted up tattered
crazy tattoos
from ankle to neck
[Laughter]
okay
uh so obi-wan tells riva that she has
honored her fallen jedi friends that she
is free now uh and then on mustafar
palpatine's hologram checks in with
vader it's like you've been too focused
on obi-wan son and vader's like okay i'm
moving on papa i love you yeah don't
worry you're my only master
you're the only one i call daddy daddy
and then the emperor is like good that's
what daddy likes to do here you go and
pick daddy again
no why am i doing uh palpatine's voice
is vader hey it's been a long night it's
been a long night yeah yeah we haven't
got a lot of sleep here so no
um so we revisit alderaan obi-wan
returns lola to leia
breaks our hearts complimenting both her
mother and her father it's john williams
leia theme and four steve play
underneath i mean that's that's the
quickest shortcut to water works for me
just play john williams leia theme and
i'm more i'm a puddle i'm alex smith the
only way i would have cried i would have
you know been more moved by that scene
because if shadow from homeward bound
had run home to that music
[Music]
oh peter
i missed you every day i was so worried
peter oh peter
[Music]
like when the did we get a dog
what what is it shoot some of the blast
what is that what is it they don't have
retrievers on this planet oh gross uh
obi-wan makes one final visit to owen
who lets obi-wan meet luke obi-wan gives
luke the t-16 skyhopper toy and we get a
hello there
they know us they know what we wanted
they know what we wanted right
and then finally qui-gon rides up on his
eop to the force ghost of qui-gon jen
who tells them he was always with them
and that they still have quite a ways to
go
so how influential was qui-gon's ghost
actually throughout this series was he
there the whole time what things that we
saw on the show were actually the doing
of qui-gon and did quite good really see
um you know everything like everything
that obi-wan did alone in that cave
i mean amanda's needs
and uh
did quaggan watch
didn't he watch
oh peter
what did you see oh obi-wan oh obi-wan
i keep hearing the old man just kind of
breathing heavily in this cave poor poor
don amici
just trying to have his bones rest in
his grave and were roasting his horny
voice at the end of homeward bound
all right um
an announcement that we have to give you
here if you're enjoying this goofy
banter or even if you're not we still
want to drag you through this new
rockstar is going to be live in austin
texas on july 4th through july 3rd for
rtx that's rooster teeth's podcast
festival it's going to be tommy and me
plus jessica clements plus phil molina
we're doing a live show saturday july
2nd as part of this festival it's going
to be so fun so click the link in the
description use the promo code new
rockstars all one word for a discounted
ticket price we hope to see you there if
you're in austin come hang out with us
we want to see you guys
don't forget after the show you can hunt
me down before the cops do in downtown
austin so it's going to be a race and
time to find me yeah i mean i think
that's texas law i think that's just
legal in texas if you see tommy you're
allowed to hunt him but there is a time
there's a time limit you know there's a
season in place there's a season there's
a tommy season
can't just do it year round there are
there's tagging rules there's bagging
rules
and uh i'll i'll give you the rules when
when you get great um
so uh this is also your last chance to
get our limited edition latest obsession
in kenobi inspired empire's most wanted
shirt available at new rockstars
merch.com it's the best way to support
us here at new rockstars and when you
get one of these you'll unlock the added
option to write on custom shout out
they'll appear at the bottom of these
after shows for example we got john who
says vader i am what you made me obi-wan
i could have sworn i made you shorter
uh that's garbage
uh charles has designed something
shouting out young leia she's nailing it
and kenobi's baby yoda or she is
kenobi's baby yoda it's brilliant i
agree charles i think uh this this leia
actress especially by the end
vivian lira blair she crushed it in this
final episode she's great
oh absolutely great uh yeah and then
dean says i want to see disney release
uh an inquisitor lightsaber that spins
so i can fly to the front of the line oh
at disneyland yeah
i think dean you got the you got some
good ideas got some good ideas
bob chapic i assume you're watching this
so um you know get dean on the
imaginarian team i think yeah bob
actually watches live as we record so he
can see the unedited version in case we
say something uh
uh negative about disney he shocks us
yeah no yeah yeah he calls it the chapic
channel on
all of his screens in his home he could
just bring it up and watch any of us
wherever we are there's floating
invisible drones that just kind of
follow us so that's right we got little
lolas that come by and yeah electrocute
us yeah
and just give us little bites just like
little nibbles like the way mosquitos
and uh you call that a chapic kiss you
know you just that's how you know he's
he's watching
he's he was there the whole time tommy
we were just not ready to see
that's true yeah that's true all right
tommy what's the question we're dealing
with this episode
i'm gonna
i'm gonna go back to
[Music]
an old an old version an old way of
telling asking these questions how's the
fact much
was qui-gon's ghost helping obi-wan
during this series
oh i had forgotten how the fed how i
missed how the fit um well this episode
ends by proving that we can never trust
actors when they say they will not be in
things both liam neeson and ian mcdarmod
denied being in obi-wan kenobi liam
neeson even had that silly excuse about
not wanting to be in anything beneath
the star wars film
we knew that wasn't true these cameos
even went a step further than what i
thought we would get tommy i thought we
were just gonna get vocal cameos but we
actually got semi-translucent forms of
them the actors had to suit up in hair
and makeup and costume
i mean i guess they could have made like
a stand-in version of palpatine he's
pretty unrecognizable under that and
just use his voice but no it looks like
him yeah i think that was really him i
think they punched in on his face in
that one point yeah when he was really
questioning darth's uh
intentions they kind of moved in close
to the hologram space so he had a bit of
an apprehensive look on his face like uh
did i make it have i made the wrong
choice
i should i should have tried to turn
mace windu i believe mole is still alive
i can fight
where's that little spider-legged boy
spider he's a spider
yeah give me a mice spider so obi-wan
has got has been calling out to qui-gon
throughout the series always met with
silence including this episode it opens
with a kind of prayer really he's like i
have to face the master whether he dies
or i do this ends today well neither of
you died but the conflict the the
hatchet in a way was buried uh this
episode ends of course with oh with
obi-wan seeing qui-gon in the wavy heat
almost as if qui-gon is just a mirage
and almost as if old man ben is losing
his mind
it actually reminds us of the way rey
saw luke and leia's force ghost at the
end of verizon skywalker almost a mirage
in the sand there i kind of wish that
whole movie was a mirage but that's you
know that's the truth of that moment
when qui-gon says uh to him well it took
you long enough and obi-wan responds i
was beginning to think it would never
come which reminded us of the you know
reading between
uh obi-wan and anakin in the flashback
last episode
and then qui-gon says i was always here
obi-wan you were just not ready to see
come on you got a ways to go now what
does this mean the implication is that
obi-wan needed to reconnect with the
force in the series
and to fully accept that anakin the
anakin that he knew and again as he knew
him is dead is gone and most importantly
we learned this episode that that death
was not solely obi-wan's fault it was
really the dark side the sith plot
manifested in lord vader that vanquished
what was left of anakin's goodness
obi-wan needed to forgive himself on the
show and realize that anakin made his
own choices to embrace the dark side
obi-wan's shame in a way is a
manifestation of the evil that palpatine
plagued on all the surviving jedi he
divided these heroes by guilting them
into thinking that they failed each
other which may be true in a way but any
empathetic person anybody with a soul
would rightly kick themselves over their
mistakes that's just something that we
do but part of self-forgiveness is also
recognizing that the way
uh we each fail ourselves and are in
control of our own choices you know and
vader's line about vader being the one
to kill anakin
was exactly what obi-wan needed to hear
he followed the path suggested by
quinlan vos that only through the
darkness he could see the way so i
believe that qui-gon was there for all
of this because we know from attack of
the clones that liam's uh
that liam neeson cameoed as the voice of
qui-gon shouting at anakin in his mind
when he attacked the tuscans he said
no
he was there with anakin i believe he's
been there with obi-wan as well
throughout the season we pointed out how
weird it is that vader and obi-wan
seemed to be able to see each other
sense each other sharing visions sharing
memories they shared a bath at one point
it was really hot
each time we've assumed it was just the
abstract force bringing them back
together but i think there was a third
sentient spirit there in the room for
each of these connections i think
qui-gon was doing some matchmaking let's
not forget that qui-gon told obi-wan and
phantom menace in that opening scene
some of the first words of that movie
obi-wan says i have a bad feeling about
this qui-gon says don't center on your
anxiety obi-wan keep your concentration
on the here and now where it belongs and
obi-wan says um master yoda says i
should be mindful of the future and
qui-gon always that great jedi shoots
back
but not at the expense of the moment be
mindful of the living force my young
padawan the living force is the element
obi-wan reconnected with in this series
not the abstract visions of the future
or the visions of the past remember the
past always came to him as nightmares
horrifying triggering things and images
but the present moment is what he needed
to be grounded in and that's where he is
now obi-wan began the series burying
that connection living in the past and
now he has found that connection to the
living force once more he has found the
way
but what do we think lies ahead for
crazy old ben and his ghost's best
friend what what what lies ahead
well they certainly left the door open
for a season too by having him pack up
his things
implying that he was leaving tatooine
something that
the speculation on certainly on the
break room and on our end over here was
like oh well he has to stay on tatooine
to watch luke but then they're like no
he releases luke into owen's care and is
like you just need to watch him now
and and i think you know
liam kind of gave uh qui-gon gave him
kind of the footprints and the sand talk
of like when you only saw one lightsaber
whose eye is because i was wielding it i
like to think like the first scene where
he really uses the force where he
catches leia when she's falling off the
building that might have been a qui-gon
like giving him a little power boost
i like you that
i i think i think they're setting us up
for another limited series i think that
there's gonna be
there's gonna be some furthering some
further adventures of obi-wan and
qui-gon uh coming in a couple of years
that's i i i imagine maybe perhaps
uh maybe an attempt to reunite with
quinlan and and uh save some other jedis
in peril or something along those lines
yeah they had that line from rokin right
i'm just getting started just getting
warmed up i mean it was interesting to
see it and end in this place like
uh obi-wan is not for the next nine or
ten years is going to have a constant
check and he's got he's got the you know
the parents for their third kid the
whole baby monitor we're gonna go down
the street and have some drinks with
friends
style of parenting totally fine that
kid's gonna be okay with owen and bru i
think he looked at peru and was like
this lady's nuts and i love this is the
safest place i could be
at the safest hands
she turns on me yeah i know i don't i
don't want to piss her off she's got
guns everywhere i mean if anything
that's uh as long as
you would hope that no i'm not going to
get into that yeah i'm not going to get
in that you just don't want luke finding
one of those guns
yeah right you got to hide them down
just keep them out of reach give them
just a little bit a little bit on the
high shelf you know lock and key you
want to see where my aunt keeps your
blaster oh god
oh my god tommy
tommy tommy tommy but um yeah i think
you're right
i know oh i know
the
uh the idea of him leaving with qui-gon
deeper into the play like i think you're
right i think it does set up obi-wan and
kind of detaches him from the plan of
tattooing for season two to team up with
broken to help other jedi escape you
know to find find the path uh tessen
interesting uh planet came up this
episode where they thought they were
gonna go
um but yeah i think um
i think the two of them like we have the
opportunity here for a wonderful buddy
series
ben and his ghost right like don't we
all want to see that just qui-gon kind
of like continue advising that like
kenobi like flirting too hard with a
woman on tested and he's in qui-gon
being like oh obi-wan you know you can't
i'm getting cock-blocked by a ghost here
or yeah he's just like the ghost in big
mouth you know up in the attic that's
that's what he does now yeah exactly uh
i love it i love that there's like
mysteries of the force that these two
can unlock in each other uh i think it's
beautiful in a way i i want to hear
qui-gon taking credit for all the cool
stuff that obi-wan did this episode
absolutely you didn't move those rocks
off yourself i moved them off one by one
it took forever uh i was one who caught
leia on daiyu you didn't see me down
there but i caught her i went
you didn't do [ __ ] it was me it's me all
this time
now use your mind to turn me into a uh
ghost now you turn into a ghost we're
doing ghost classes now all right let's
talk about reeva this episode but first
we want to thank some friends who helped
us make it starting with our friends at
manscaped there's certain confidence
that comes with being properly groomed
there's an aura a vibe as powerful as
the force itself but you can also call
it bge big groomed energy there's only
one way to get that bge and it's
manscaped they have introduced their
best and biggest ultimate hygiene bundle
yet the platinum package 4.0 manscaped
is the leader in below the waist
grooming now trust them with the rest
join the 4 million men worldwide who
trust manscape by going to manscape.com
for 20 off plus free shipping with the
code wookie manscape's brand new
platinum package 4.0 is the biggest
bundle they've offered giving you a bulk
discount on manscape's top products
inside this platinum package you'll find
their lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker
ear nose hair trimmer ultra premium body
wash ultra premium two in one shampoo
and conditioner and a bunch of other
great stuff that all comes in the shed
travel bag to hold your goods while
traveling the lawnmower 4.0 body trimmer
and weed whacker knows the near hair
trimmer future proprietary advanced skin
safe technology to protect your delicate
parts and holes both are waterproof so
you can shave with less mess the
platinum package 4.0 covers all bases
from trimming to showering to leaving
the gym smelling nice this is the best
bang for your buck get 20 off and free
shipping with the code wookie at
manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com and use the
code wookie unlock your big groom energy
with manscape and remember when you trim
the hedges the tree stands taller all
right
tommy let's talk about riva this episode
uh what is next for riva or is she gonna
get her own spin-off or would you want
to see her in season two i
i i would like to see her it crossed
paths with obi-wan again in season two i
i don't i don't know if a whole spin-off
i mean i think
that could be interesting i just
i feel like that could add a real i
think that could make a nice b storyline
for a season two is like
riva crossing paths with obi-wan again
and like
what does that mean now like let's like
let's let like
six months pass between the seasons you
know what i mean like or like a year
pass because we can't let too much time
pass or then he's gonna have to go back
to tattooed so it's like let's let's
rejoin the burgeoning rebellion with uh
with with broken and and and see if riva
has maybe begrudgingly
joined up with them or if she's found
another
you know is there another organization
that is like sympathetic to uh former
jedis or former padawans is there like
yeah is there like a ragtag group of
surviving padawans that she can go and
join i don't know yeah see i don't know
uh what is left for riva um
because like i don't know she's done a
lot of horrible things right in her path
and i i get it so if vader can be
redemptive anybody can then again like
it was easier to watch vader's
redemption in return of the jedi before
we saw all the things he did in this
series and in rogue one and in rebels
and read the comics and all the horrible
things he did yeah it's all obviously
revenge of the sith where he killed
children like yeah we didn't know how
how awful he got uh we just saw him
choke a bunch of like nazi imperial
officers yeah original trilogy it was
easier to stomach that um yeah anyway
but uh yeah so riva i think like if her
plan was to just get revenge on vader
like
there was a lot of opportunities she had
to take a swing at the old man uh he's
not that old but um she could have
gotten she didn't have to like take him
on this wild goose chase of you know
kidnapping leia and
following them to mapuzo and all this
stuff like think of all the people who
were killed as uh throughout this series
like the people in mapoo we saw a little
kid's neck get snapped that was horrible
that whole death parade that vader went
on uh yeah did ripa need to really go
through all that perhaps there could be
like a star wars version of thunderbolts
or suicide squad with like black
cursantin
uh riva and someone else like teaming up
to like
like take take a uh large sum of money
to
like save a village or save a save a
planet or something like that i don't
know you know what i want to see for
arifa is like
i want to see her go back to the
fortress inquisitorius and like burn
that place to the ground yeah see what
happens like if she will be the ulti
like if she changes from a jedi hunter
to an inquisitor hunter you know
uh like because obviously we see what
happens to a lot of these inquisitors
throughout the course of star wars
comics and through throughout rebels um
and you know there's there's all these
stories but there's so many unanswered
questions about the inquisitors so she
goes inquisitor by inquisitor and tries
to either redeem them and if they don't
if they fight her she just kills him
like i think she now her list is like
the grand inquisitor the
fifth brother the seventh sister the
ninth sister the eighth brother the
mountain
jamie lannister cersei lannister uh
cottonmouth bud
yeah so i think that's her list now i
think she's an inquisitor hunter i think
that's to me the most exciting future
for her is that she
she is uh
she doesn't really have any hope for
herself like i think she has her own
tally marks the way tala had hash marks
on her blaster holster she needs to now
uh one by one redeem each of the
of the prey that she has hunted over the
years i like it i like the idea i like
that pitch for her um i also don't need
a second season of this to be honest
with you like i think like
there's plenty of stories that are gonna
get told like broken right could come
back in and or and or is gonna just pick
up a few years after this maybe what
four or five years after this uh and
we're gonna have 24 episodes to fill on
andor so yeah plenty of uh prequel era
um stuff that stories that can be told
on andor uh by the way i believe andor
will be our next live-action star wars
series that we're going to talk about
here on wikileaks coming at the end of
august it's just really just really um
a riva light speed jump away by the way
whisper away guys yeah you know we're
just we're gonna do i'm sure we're gonna
have some more kenobi
aftershocks to break down some some news
will come out and then just when you're
like god when is wikileaks gonna cover
these tv shows again and or will drop
and all will be right with the galaxy
mm-hmm uh i want to leave us with the
chance final thoughts on this uh we'll
be talking about it more but just like
after watching the finale
how are you how are you feeling about
these six episodes i overall i very much
enjoyed uh the story the path that it
took us a lot on i uh i was surprised
by some of the ways that it went
certainly from what my
thoughts and expectations from watching
the trailers and and whatever we're
gonna be but overall i thought the
landing was very satisfying and stuck i
think the second vader kenobi fight paid
off the first fight more when you
realized that obi-wan had to get better
and get stronger and he really like it
made me appreciate how weak he was in
that first fight that allowed him to be
so dominated by vader and then just kind
of saved at the last moment which i
really appreciated i loved the portrayal
of uh
of uh
young leia i thought even the characters
that didn't like my whole thought i was
after the first couple of officers i was
like why did they bring joel etching and
however you say last name back
to do these things and it was the it's
because they had such a huge role in in
the final episode i thought they were
amazing i i you know
uh this ranks probably somewhere in the
middle for these disney star wars series
for me not it's not any i it doesn't go
above mandalorian for me but i i overall
give me that last episode up against
anything they've done for tv uh 100
it leaves such a nice taste in our mouth
as we end this series and i i think they
absolutely did stuck the stick the
landing it reminds me of uh you know
what they describe improv adds to us
when we're taking level one improv
classes it's nine people falling down a
flight of stairs together and trying to
all land on their feet at the other end
and uh that's what it felt like here it
felt like there was a couple of moments
a couple steps where we bumped our head
on the step it felt a little concussed
but then we stopped the landing which is
fine because ultimately all the pieces
were
were in place for this finale
everything that they they made so many
great choices for what to include and
what not to include in the series but i
will say episode the episode i i think
they should have just introduced some
stuff earlier and revealed some stuff
earlier and not tried to play this game
of we're going to keep this a secret
like
why didn't we just know the whole time
that revo was that yeah padawan that
didn't need to be a reveal i think that
reveal kind of landed as a well duh thud
like i don't think anyone was surprised
by that it would have informed her
character more
clearly i i think the writing on riva i
think the acting on revo was incredible
uh moses ingram is my new favorite
actress she's incredible she's so good
um but i think the writing for her
character was uh just kind of all over
the place like i didn't know
why they uh like even in this episode i
don't know what her plans are for luke
when she gets him and why she wants to
kill luke i'm like yes there probably is
a a reason that i'm missing right now
but i'm telling you the morning after i
watch the show i don't know why she
wanted to kill luke skywalker and that's
a problem right
in fact i think in general the
inquisitors really well acted on this
series man rupert friend
swinging for the fences uh just
incredible acting choices but just
i was really hoping uh for the
inquisitors for like people who didn't
watch rebels or or play fall in order to
know how terrifying the inquisitors are
i think the inquisitors are just a
little poopy on this show like i just
think they were a little uh thinly
written and unmotivated uh and i think
just kind of introduced because they
didn't want to have them fighting vader
every episode uh but i left this series
being a little less afraid of the
inquisitors when you should be terrified
of them they are hunters and i think
they they started strong with the grand
inquisitor's speech in uh in that
cantina and then after that they never
really recaptured that high of
intimidation but overall like i think
uh like
the idea of obi-wan uh having to rescue
leia i think is just great i like
introducing the path i think was really
fun uh i think these beats that we get
between vader and obi-wan make it all
worth it like the journey was just
incredible so i i don't really have too
many complaints by the end of the show
uh i just think we don't need to make
everything a mystery as we go along just
like i think audiences prefer to have
information and know where characters
are coming from well absolutely i think
you know
you know as the i mean they kind of
ripped the band-aid in the um
sequels the
the most recent trilogy with kylo ren
like they immediately identified him as
han solo and leia's son right like it
was like yeah it was like it was like 20
minutes into the movie when you found
out like it wasn't like there was no i
am your father at the end also
interesting parallel
this is the second time we get uh when
owen yelled out ben i was like oh it's
kind of like the han solo
[Laughter]
i i very much enjoyed this week to week
like i don't want to sound like i'm too
down on it overall i really really
enjoyed this and i uh i don't think you
did eric i thought i thought what you
just said was really thoughtful i mean
these shows aren't above colleen and
inquisitor poopy is super powerful
but i think i don't know the essence of
what you said is like very true
i could have for my money i know we're
wrapping up and then i just said let me
introduce something new for my money
they could have never had the first
the grand inquisitor die
it could have just been riva's constant
disobedience pushed her onto the outside
and then she like in a desperation move
lashes out at vader and then it's like
like she's in the disciplinary hearing
and then that's the like all right now
we're off in this three you know this
this this three-way tango of obi-wan
riva and vader i don't know that the
grand inquisitor ever had to go away i
think kind of taking him off the board
made them by nature less scary and then
they just didn't the what is it the
fifth brother he was just kind of he
disappeared after episode four we never
saw him again yeah i don't think you
need the inquisitors at all in this
story yeah it's a hot tank right here i
don't think the inquisitors do anything
and contribute really anything in the
story i think uh riva's storyline was
just so written to be so muddy by the
end uh and i think like
uh you know tala indira varma an
incredible character on this show like i
think they did such a good job
introducing new characters with uh that
we didn't know existed in star wars
history uh or at least even the category
of this character we didn't know existed
uh i think they really did moses synchro
dirty by by the writing of this
character uh i think they could have
written a completely different character
for her and she would have crushed it uh
she did she crushed it she she did the
best she possibly could i think these
actors are so good the fact that they
can make us feel things uh they can stir
our emotions and make it honest and true
and and uh painful this journey for them
i think we have to applaud moses ingram
on this show absolutely incredible um i
i just think like in general when you're
writing these characters like feel free
to just completely bring someone out of
left field and and tell a new story with
the character because yeah you know
i think hopefully that's what tyka is
going to do with his stand-alone movie
come on taika help us taika you're our
only hope yep uh we'll leave it there
for this episode of wikileaks but again
we're gonna be talking about what we
just went through on this series over
the weeks ahead and look ahead to andor
a lot of fun stuff coming up in star
wars uh my easter egg breakdown of this
episode is going to come tomorrow tommy
and i are going to be back uh every week
we haven't picked a day yet but i think
we're going to be on mondays for
wikileaks we'll find out um and don't
forget to check out our great merch
options at
follow me at ea newrockstarsmerch.com
follow tommy and tommy back don't follow
the new rockstar subscribe to wikileaks
forever your podcast thank you for
watching and
we have spoken and goodbye
you